Pope wearing a dripped out Balenciaga
jacket French president Emmanuel macron
running away from protesters Donald
Trump being wrestled To The Ground by
cops we've all seen these images and we
know they're fake but can you imagine a
computer generating something like this
even five years ago everyone is talking
about Ai and what it means for our
society Sam Altman is testifying in
front of Congress but not enough people
are talking about what I think is one of
the most interesting AI companies in the
world mid-journey it's become by far the
best way to create AI generated images
and it's also one of the most
fascinating stories in the history of
Silicon Valley David holes Grew
mid-journey From nothing into a real
business that likely makes tens of
millions in profit in about a year the
way he did it holds so many interesting
lessons for the future of tech and
Entrepreneurship so let's Dive In
[Music]
mid-journey has become by far the best
way to make AI generated images these
posters behind me were actually
generated by mid-journey the company
makes tons of money even though the team
is really small and as I'm recording
this there are 18 million people in
their Discord in a way it's crazy how
quickly this has all happened but this
overnight success story actually took
years to happen before David holes
became one of the most important leaders
in AI he ran a company that never really
took off and long before then he was a
curious kid from South Florida David's
dad was a dentist but not your average
dentist his office was on a boat and he
would sail around the Caribbean in South
America where he'd pull up to port and
do dental work for people once David
came along his dad settled down and
rented out an office near Fort
Lauderdale because of his job David's
dad had a computer of course David
quickly became obsessed he learned how
to program in this really old language
called scheme he even started hacking
computer games one of his favorites was
this old dos game called Star Wars dark
Forces I actually remember this game you
played as this guy named Kyle katarn who
discovers this top secret Galactic
Empire project I was obsessed with this
stuff as a kid and used to read tons of
these Star Wars spin-off books anyway
David hacked the game so that Kyle could
shoot Rockets out of his hands and stuff
like that basically he modded it this is
such a classic trajectory for people who
get into Tech lots of time on the
computer gaming little bits of
programming and then more serious
projects later on David applied the
skills he learned really early on he ran
a design business while still in high
school he attended tons of science fairs
and even ended up judging a few of them
so it probably didn't come as a surprise
to any of David's friends or family when
he decided to study Physics in college
David really admired the great
physicists people like Einstein Newton
and Feynman as he spent more time in
college he also took lots of math
courses he ended up graduating with
degrees in both and then started a PhD
in applied math David was clearly super
smart and people were taking notice
while he was doing his PhD he started
working as a graduate researcher at the
max plan Institute named after the
famous theoretical physicist he also
worked for NASA at their Langley campus
he was doing really cool stuff mapping
rat brains atmospheric science even
working on lidar but at a certain point
David became worried that he was getting
locked into a career path where he would
just do research write papers and then
nothing really happened he wanted to
make a bigger impact he wanted something
that could become his sole Focus so
David did with lots of super smart
slightly aimless people do he started a
company the company's first name was ocu
spec but that wasn't a great name so
David and his co-founder soon changed it
to Leap Motion the idea for lead
motion's main product actually came to
David back in middle school he was in a
typing class and he must have been bored
because the teacher told him if he could
type more than 60 words a minute without
looking at the keyboard he didn't have
to do the class so David learned how to
type really fast got out of the class
and then all of a sudden he had time to
work on other projects that experience
of learning how to type fast made David
did realize that there was a problem
with how people interacted with
technology I know most middle school
students never think about stuff like
this basically he thought that there was
a bottleneck people's minds worked
really fast but seamlessly transmitting
that information was difficult cost size
and speed are all important factors but
for David the most important thing was
the interaction model the end result of
that thinking was the leap a small
device you'd place in front of your
computer that would track the motion of
your hands and then translate those
gestures into commands but well before
the leap was released in fact even
before David founded Leap Motion he had
an interaction that foreshadowed the
debate we're having today about AI lead
motion kind of invented a lot of
gestural interface technology but people
weren't really ready the iPad had only
just been released and the Windows
operating system didn't yet work with
touch screens at all people didn't
really think about touch beyond their
phones and the trackpad on their laptops
of course today touches everywhere and
apple recently announced the Vision Pro
which includes hand tracking is a core
feature but it's taken more than 10
years after leap motion's first product
to get us here because lead motion was
trying to do something new David was
very focused on user interaction one of
the people he talked to early on was a
professor named Alan K Allen is a
legendary computer scientist who
basically invented both object-oriented
programming and the graphical user
interface and he said something which
crystallized the problem David was
trying to solve don't think about
features think about how the user learns
in many ways Leap Motion never really
solved that problem they tried to
introduce a new technological Paradigm
before people were truly ready for it
but today user education both in terms
of people learning how to use the
technology and also how people train the
algorithm is a big part of why
mid-journey is so amazing Leap Motion
had a promising first few years their
seed round in 2011 received investments
from Andreessen Horowitz and Founders
fund but not every VC knew what Leap
Motion was trying to do there's a great
story for when David was first pitching
investors he's in a room full of VCS
they're all wearing 3D glasses David
pulls a mountain out of the wall rotates
it and pushes it back into the wall it
was kind of like Minority Report at that
the lead investor took off his pair of
glasses stepped forward and said with
total confidence I get it after a rough
week this was like music to David's ears
I just have one question the VC said can
you also track things in two Dimensions
David responded that because 3D is more
complex the device could definitely
handle working in 2D the VC nodded and
then asked David have you ever
considered giving the first two
Dimensions away for free and then
charging for the third dimension David
said that no he hadn't but that it was a
really interesting idea and one that he
promised to think about they never spoke
again the story is interesting because
it shows that bad VCS don't bother to
think about what a technology can really
do and instead they just jump right
ahead to how much money it can make all
while destroying the core value
proposition but it's also a story about
people misunderstanding the kind of
problems David was facing he didn't have
a monetization problem he was trying to
solve novel Hardware problems it's
possible that experience soured David on
VCS in general I'll go into this in more
detail later on but mid-journey hasn't
raised a scent of external funding it's
totally bootstrapped lead motion however
followed a more conventional path after
the successful seed funding round they
raised 12.75 million in series a funding
in 2012 and then a 30 million dollar
series B round in 2013 led by Founders
fund that gave them the money to release
the leap in mid-2013. it sold about 500
000 units apparently that was below
expectations but I think it's actually
pretty solid for a new hardware company
selling a totally new type of product
right out of the gate but there were
issues tech support was tricky user
retention wasn't great and that sales
figure was probably bumped up by
Partnerships with other companies in
addition to direct sales still Leap
Motion was doing well enough that Apple
was interested in acquiring them but
David the founder and CTO wasn't
interested in fact he apparently told
Apple's Representatives that their
company was no longer Innovative and
even praised Android needless to say the
deal didn't go through but still there's
an interesting alternative history here
at the time Apple actually acquired a
few companies like Prime sense that had
technology that will end up being used
in The Vision Pro had Apple bought Leap
Motion around the same time who knows
how that would have affected the
creation of mid-journey or for that
matter the Vision Pro I remember there
being some Buzz about Leap Motion around
this time people thought they were
building a cool new technology and they
were interested to see where it would go
the company sent about 12 000 of its
devices to developers who were
interested in building apps that used
hand tracking technology by now Leap
Motion had pivoted away from the desktop
input of their first product and toured
virtual reality but it wasn't obvious
how their Tech would be integrated into
existing VR products there was an
external kit you could add on to the
Oculus which would let you use the Leap
Motion controller but that just added a
layer of complexity to a device which to
be honest people were trying to wrap
their heads around anyway in 2014 the
Facebook bought Oculus after that the VR
industry sort of cooled down a bit but
in 2018 a few years after their first
attempt which went so badly that David
ended up basically insulting them Apple
came back and made another attempt to
buy Leap Motion for her to buy lead
motion this time was only around 30 to
50 million dollars which was just a
fraction of the 306 million dollar
valuation after the series B round it
would have been a massive drop in
valuation investors would have only been
getting cents on the dollar and the
founders and employees probably would
have received basically nothing despite
all that the deal almost happened it
even got to the point where Apple sent
out offer letters to Leap Motion
employees who were happy that they'd get
the chance to keep working on cool
attack from inside one of the world's
biggest companies but it fell through
and we never got that version of History
around this time Leap Motion which now
had around 100 employees built and open
source their augmented reality headset
Northstar underpinned by their hand
tracking technology the decision to open
source the North Star was an interesting
attempt to overcome some of the problems
that have plagued VR headsets basically
VR is really hard it's a combination of
software and Hardware the technology has
to be dynamic and responsive to user
experience the headset has to be
comfortable and there have to be enough
interesting apps for people to actually
want to use them when you look at how
long it's taken for Apple to develop the
Vision Pro and how expensive it'll be on
release you get a sense of how tricky VR
headsets really are so David's decision
to open source the development was
really smart and I think mid-journey is
a perfect example of how that commitment
to collaborative peer-driven development
can work but the North Star didn't
really go anywhere under leap motion and
frankly neither was leap motion as a
whole it was never a Bad Company it was
a good company with really interesting
and novel technology behind it but it
just never took off the product Market
fit was just never there when it came to
the leap people weren't quite ready for
the attack and when it came to the North
Star VR headset technology just wasn't
quite mature enough to be built outside
of a massive tech company like Facebook
if the market isn't ready for your
product no matter how good it is you're
in trouble in May of 2019 Leap Motion
was bought by a company called Ultra
haptics the financials weren't great it
was a 30 million dollar deal way down
from the peak valuation so employees
with stock probably got wiped out but
from a technological perspective it made
a lot of sense Ultra haptics had been
working with David in Leap Motion for
about six years by this point and they
worked on interesting technology Ultra
haptics makes virtual control solutions
that let someone feel an object in their
hands when they interact with it in
virtual reality without needing to use
gloves today lead motion is called Ultra
leap and it's unclear where their hand
control sensing technology is headed but
it's growing there are some cars that
let you turn up the volume on your sound
system by spinning your hand but in
general people aren't using their hands
to interact with computers just yet
David ran Leap Motion for almost 10
years he got a ton of experience
building new technology raising money
and growing a company from nothing into
something that Apple tried to buy twice
it was time for the next adventure he
set up a studio to explore new
opportunities he told himself to wait
until the right one came up as it turned
out he wouldn't have to wait very long
David holes chose to become an
entrepreneur instead of an academic
because he wanted to make a big impact
so this next part is kind of ironic
because an academic paper was about to
change his life in June of 2020 three
Berkeley researchers Jonathan ho AJ Jane
and Peter abiel published their Research
into how diffusion models can create
images David had enough technical
knowledge to understand that diffusion
models were about to increase the
quality of AI images by an order of
magnitude he realized that the
opportunity he'd been waiting for had
arrived the first version of openai's
Dali model proved him right but in
Reverse today Dolly 2 is one of the
leading AI image generators but when the
first one was released in January of
2021 not that many people actually paid
attention Dali 1 was the first text to
image model based on diffusion models
that existed it was a step change from
everything that came before The Dali 1
launch also include a package called
clip which could evaluate how well an
image aligned with text inputs plenty of
AI researchers had tried to build image
generators before but using older
methods like generative adversarial
networks and variational autoencoders
people who were paying close attention
like David was knew that this was a
turning point Sam Altman the head of
openai wasn't exactly sitting around
either Dali 2 was released in April of
2022 stable diffusion followed in August
and mid-journey entered open Beta in
July David holes was actually
experimenting with the preliminary
mid-journey model as far back as January
before Dali 2 dropped doing things like
creating vaporwave monkeys in the
mid-journey Discord the Discord went
public a couple months later this was
actually a really important Milestone
because it allowed David and his team to
go really hard on user testing for
example one model took about 20 minutes
to create a really high quality image
while another took about only 15 seconds
but produced worse images the first
approach was really fast but it
sacrificed quality the second approach
was resulted in amazing images but users
would often get bored in the end David
found a great midpoint today it takes
mid-journey about 60 seconds to generate
an image and it shows you the image as
it's generating there were lots of
interesting trade-offs like this the
open Beta landed on July 12th it blew up
just a few weeks later John Oliver did a
segment about it roast beef superhero
now what does that look like I have no
idea but here's what mid Journeys AI
created based on that phrase and I have
to say well played robot the crazy thing
is that even since that segment aired
less than a year ago the images you can
create using the same exact prompt have
gotten way better around the same time
an image generated by mid-journey won
the Colorado state fairs contest for
emerging digital artists it's a really
beautiful image and it's a cool proof of
concept for the mid-journey Discord the
guy who won the prize was invited to the
Discord in summer of 2022. he became
obsessed right away he was making
hundreds of images sometimes in
collaboration with other users and was
always amazed at what mid-journey could
do after he won the winning image ended
up on Twitter the reaction was furious
people said he'd plagiarized the work of
real artists someone even said they were
watching the death of artistry unfold
right before their eyes there were
people who defended him but they were in
the minority I totally understand that
lots of people feel like mid-journey is
letting people take credit for stuff
they didn't create and that it's taking
opportunities away from quote unquote
real artists but I think that's not
quite the right way to look at it David
says he views artists as customers of
mid-journey not competitors artists are
using mid-journey to prototype Concepts
to show clients before they start work
themselves that's really cool and
hopefully it'll mean more people
commission work from real artists of
course by 2023 mid-journey was making
super realistic images like those ones
of the Pope and Trump and that's kicked
off another debate about the potential
of mid-journey and other generative AI
models to contribute to misinformation
that pretty much brings us up to the
present day but there's so much more
about mid-journey both as a product and
a business that makes it such a
fascinating case study so let's explore
that in detail the hardest thing about
building an AI company today is the
intense public scrutiny you've got Sam
Altman in front of Congress and lots of
people who literally believe that
programs like chat GPT should be illegal
but despite that pressure David's built
mid-journey into the best AI image
generator around and he's done it by
implementing four distinct strategies
number one harnessing the power of
Discord you can measure the growth of
most companies by looking at their
revenues but the best way to measure the
growth of mid-journey is by looking at
their Discord if you go on sites like
Reddit you'll see the same question pop
up again and again why did the
mid-journey team decide to wrap their
product inside a Discord server it's a
fair question frankly lots of tech CEOs
would be too skittish to ever do
something like that but David
immediately understood that Discord
could be an amazing feedback loop he
believed that one of the key drivers to
Mid Journey's massive growth would be
virality and then one of the best ways
to create virality is volume today
mid-journey is the world's biggest
server by far it hit 2 million
subscribers in mid-september 2022. 4
million by the second week of November
by April it hit 15 million and as I'm
recording this there are more than 18
million members that's exponential
growth the more people in the Discord
the more people creating amazing images
and the more amazing images you see then
the more likely you are to want to join
the Discord Discord just makes sense
it's flexible and functional it has a
great mobile app and it's collaborative
one of the biggest threats to the growth
of a generative AI model is that it's
actually really hard to come up with a
good prompt especially by yourself
people aren't normally very creative by
themselves they might ask mid-journey to
do something like create an image of a
dog and after some encouragement they
might put in terms like fluffy dog or
big fluffy dog but on the mid-journey
Discord you can literally ask 18 million
other people for ideas so you end up
with cooler prompts and you're more
likely to keep using mid-journey the
Discord also acts as a sounding board
and decision making Forum the moderators
hold Town Halls where people can
advocate for the inclusion or exclusion
of certain words or phrases there are
tears and some words can only be used
for private images and it's where the
rules are made and enforced users aren't
allowed to create deep fakes not safe
for work content is generally banned and
you're not allowed to create images of
controversial political figures like Xi
Jinping given how much scrutiny there is
about AI at the moment it's a really
smart idea to have mid-journey's entire
Global user base in one place Discord
also helps train the mid-journey model
when you use a model like stable
diffusion you don't have a chance to
provide feedback to the model trainer
with mid-journey you proactively select
from four different images to confirm
which is the best one and the model
retains that data the unique way that
mid-journey harnesses the power of
Discord is proof that David was
listening closely to what Professor Alan
K told him just focus on how the user
learns two product Market fit
like lots of people in Tech David has a
big bias for Action he has a really
interesting quote about it many of my
brilliant friends are paralyzed by their
intellects thinking overwhelms doing
many of my successful friends are less
reflective but quick to action they are
always focused on moving forward making
as many probably correct actions as
possible a winning strategy this quote
reminds me of his struggles about
whether or not to stay in Academia he
probably met lots of people like that
super smart people who needed things to
be perfect but David realized he was
different and that difference that bias
to action is really important in AI even
by the standards of software generative
AI is moving insanely fast like I said
we're already at V5 of mid-journey there
isn't time to hone something to
Perfection instead David releases a
minimum viable product uses mid
Journey's massive super engaged user
base to make it better and keeps
iterating its modern software
development at top speed and David is
taking a very different approach from
other AI companies lots of AI companies
are fighting right now to become an
infrastructure layer and don't want to
focus on building a consumer product
they want to build a platform you know
what that reminds me of it reminds me of
when David when he was still at lead
motion sent thousands of hand tracking
devices to developers so they could
develop apps and it reminds me of VR
headsets that have really amazing
Hardware but no killer app everyone
wants to create a platform because
that's where the big monetization
opportunities are but if you don't
create a great product then the platform
doesn't matter Leap Motion never really
took off because despite having Cool
Tech it didn't give enough people a
reason to use it mid-journey is
different artists use it to improve
their practice but mostly tons of
regular people use it because they're
curious to see what it can do if you
make your available Market everyone
online and then make your product
incredibly easy and fun to use then
you're going to get great product Market
fit three focusing on need
right now the era of low interest rates
and easy VC money feels like a long time
ago a company that makes Hardware based
on speculative technology like Leap
Motion might not get off the ground it
probably wouldn't raise 100 million
dollars I'm not saying David could see
where interest rates were going when he
started mid-journey but he did make a
deliberate choice to totally bootstrap
the company David was a known quantity
in Silicon Valley he probably could have
gone out and raised lots of money for
anything instead he did something way
better he consulted his years of
experience and asked himself what is the
scarce resource I need more of to truly
scale the answer wasn't actually money
it was compute so when mid-journey was
just starting out he leveraged his
Network he did stuff like email Cloud
vendors and asked to lock down access to
gpus to scale his service it's not just
about capacity either David remembered
that in the early days of the Discord
some people were getting frustrated with
how long it would take to generate high
quality images so today mid-journey
actively searches for gpus in parts of
the world where it's night in order to
accelerate the process that dynamic load
balancing is what's enabled it to
consistently keep rendering times pretty
low two other entrepreneurs investors
Nat Friedman and Daniel gross have made
the same realization as David that there
are startups that need compute way more
than money that's why they launched the
Andromeda cluster a massive Cloud Server
specifically for startups it's a small
but fascinating shift in what's valuable
and the value that investors can provide
particularly when money is tight David's
experience shows that you don't
necessarily need to wait until interest
rates go down again to start a company
you just need to identify what you need
most and then focus on obtaining as much
of it as you can four the value of
learning
mid Journey gets better by learning from
its past experiences so did David he
spent almost a decade running leap
motion and before that he spent years in
Academia he's been an active member of
the AI Community absorbing the technical
knowledge and the philosophical debates
all of those experiences made him a
better founder CEO and engineer and just
as importantly David isn't done learning
he holds four hour long sessions with
thousands of people on Discord to answer
questions and see how everyone's doing
he's constantly tinkering with
mid-journey itself and looking for ways
to make it a better product and he's
still constantly thinking about the
place of AI in our society and how it
can contribute to making us better David
gave an interview last August where he
really grappled with this idea he ended
up comparing it to water water is
dangerous but it's also a driver of
civilization and we're better off as
humans who know how to live with and
work with water it's an opportunity it
has no will it has no Spite and yes you
can drown in it but that doesn't mean we
should ban water and when you discover a
new source of water it's a really good
thing all lots of people worry that AI
will make millions of jobs obsolete or
that it'll Rise Up Against Humanity but
not enough people think the way David
does that AI can be dangerous if it's
handled the wrong way but that it can
also be this amazing life-changing
resource it took David Holes about 20
years to go from starting College to
leaving Leap Motion but it only took him
about a year to grow mid-journey from an
idea into the world's leading AI image
generating tool that makes millions of
dollars every month and he didn't need a
cent of venture capital to do it all he
really needed was years of experience
and the same curiosity he had when he
was a kid playing Star Wars dark Forces
on his dad's computer if to learn more
about how we should regulate AI to avoid
making the same mistakes that we did
with nuclear just watch this video next
thanks a lot